mira al metano tenemos 4 protones
equivalentes por lo que esperaríamos una
señal en el espectro de rm n esta es la
señal para los protones en el metano
esta señal ocurre aproximadamente en una
parte por millón y recuerda de los
primeros vídeos de la rm n de protones a
qué se refiere esa señal se refiere a la
diferencia en energía entre el estado de
spin alfa y el beta este es el estado de
spin alfa y este es el estado de spin
beta hay una diferencia de energía entre
estos dos estados de espn y esta
diferencia de energía corresponde a una
frecuencia porque él es igual a h
y la diferencia de energía también
corresponde al campo magnético efectivo
sentido por los protones si dibujo el
campo magnético aquí el campo magnético
efectivo
controla la diferencia de energía
pensemos en esto si yo tengo un cierto
campo magnético efectivo obtengo una
cierta diferencia de energía entre el
estado de spin alfa y el beta la energía
corresponde a la frecuencia que es
absorbida y entonces esta señal es una
cierta frecuencia dijimos antes que ésta
era una frecuencia más baja esta es una
señal de fred
bueno
sea
más
ja
esta es una señal de baja frecuencia y
en un vídeo anterior hablamos de cómo
comparar la frecuencia con el
desplazamiento químico así que una baja
frecuencia te da un desplazamiento
químico bajo 1 es un desplazamiento
químico bajo aquí y entonces los
protones en el metano están blind
da dos comparados con los protones en el
clorometano así que de amosal
clorometano ahora para el clorometano
tenemos tres protones equivalentes una
señal en nuestro espectro de rn y esta
señal ocurre apenas pasando 3
aproximadamente en 3.1 partes por millón
y veamos si podemos entender por qué
sucede esto ahora tenemos un átomo
electro negativo el cloro es mucho más
electro negativo que el carbono
el cloro va a tomar algo de densidad
electrónica y entonces el cloro se
vuelve parcialmente negativo
le damos al carbono la carga
parcialmente positiva el cloro toma
densidad electrónica de estos protones
estos protones están des blindados del
campo magnético aplicado aquí tenemos
protones
blind
da
dos protones deslindados si los protones
están des blindados del campo magnético
aplicado eso significa que esos protones
experimentan un campo magnético efectivo
mayor déjame continuar dibujando esto y
voy a exagerar para que se entienda el
punto un campo magnético efectivo mayor
para un protón significa una mayor
diferencia en energía entre tu estado
destina alfa y el beta aquí están los
estados de espín alfa y el beta ahora ya
que tenemos un protón deslindado tenemos
una mayor diferencia en energía entre
nuestros estados de espn y la energía
corresponde a una frecuencia así que un
campo magnético efectivo mayor significa
una diferencia de energía mayor
significa una frecuencia más alta la
frecuencia más alta absorbida esta sería
una fría
bueno sea
más
alta
comparada con comparada con el ejemplo
previo todo es relativo aquí así que es
una señal de frecuencia más alta
comparada con los protones en el metal y
entonces obtenemos un valor mayor para
el desplazamiento químico hagamos un
resumen de esto rápidamente un protón
blindado te dará una señal de frecuencia
más baja y por ende un valor menor para
el desplazamiento químico un protón
deslindado te dará una señal de
frecuencia mayor y un desplazamiento
químico mayor nuevamente sólo comparando
estas dos cosas eso es lo que hace la
electro negatividad entre más aquí tengo
mi átomo electro negativo que está
deslindando al protón le está dando un
mayor desplazamiento químico y esa es la
idea aplicamos esto a un gráfico que
tiene un conjunto de diferentes grupos
funcionales aquí
pensemos en los diferentes
desplazamientos químicos para los
protones en diferentes ambientes
apenas dijimos que si les brindas al
protón obtendrás una señal de mayor
frecuencia y por lo tanto un
desplazamiento químico mayor a esto se
le conoce como campo abajo así que el
lado izquierdo de este espectro de rm n
aquí están los protones más des
blindados a la derecha del espectro de
rm n
estamos hablando de protones más
blindados por lo que hay una señal de
menor frecuencia por lo tanto hay un
desplazamiento químico menor y puedes
utilizar el término anterior campo
arriba si quieres también apenas
hablamos del metano estamos hablando de
un tipo de ambiente alcano por lo que el
protón en un carbono en un ambiente tipo
alcano el desplazamiento químico esto es
esto es un protón blindado esperaríamos
una señal de baja frecuencia un
desplazamiento químico bajo algo dentro
del intervalo de 0.5 a 2
es donde esperaríamos una señal para un
protón en un ambiente tipo arcano un
valor dentro de este intervalo esos
están más blindados luego hablamos de
clorometano cierto y en el clorometano
tenemos un átomo electro negativo en un
carbono que estaba unido a nuestro
protón y entonces está esa es la
situación déjame usar amarillo para esto
aquí tenemos como un átomo electro
negativo podrías pensar en algo como
cloro o flúor o un halógeno o podemos
pensar en un oxígeno que también es
electro negativo la aie es un átomo
electro negativo
la aie toma densidad electrónica de este
carbono y des brinda este protón que
está directamente en ese carbono así que
des brindar el protón te da un
desplazamiento químico más alto y
entonces tu desplazamiento esperado es
de aproximadamente 2.5
punto 5 si ves una señal en el intervalo
de 2.5 a 4.5 podría ser un protón que
esté en un carbono que esté directamente
unido a un átomo electro negativo como
una halógeno o un oxígeno entre esos dos
ejemplos la señal para este protón de
aquí este protón mostrará
aproximadamente de 2 a 2.5 y entonces
este protón está directamente unido a un
carbono pero este carbono no está
directamente unido a un átomo electro
negativo pero está unido a este carbono
que es un carbón y lo aquí este oxígeno
es más electro negativo este oxígeno
toma algo de densidad electrónica pero
no tanto como en este ejemplo con este
átomo electro negativo directamente en
este carbono y entonces la señal el
desplazamiento químico está entre estos
valores un protón que está en un carbono
que está al lado de un carbón y lo lo
veremos aproximadamente
de 2 a 2.5 nuevamente todos estos son
sólo intervalos aproximados intento dar
números lindos y simples aquí fáciles de
recordar luego veamos al protón en
nuestro alcohol justo aquí los alcoholes
tienen enlaces de hidrógeno y el enlace
de hidrógeno tiene un efecto des
blindado un incremento en los enlaces de
hidrógeno significa una disminución en
el blindaje la premisa es que la
cantidad de enlaces de hidrógeno depende
de cosas como concentración y
temperatura y como esas cosas pueden
variar obtienes diferentes cantidades de
enlaces de hidrógeno y diferentes
cantidades de deslindar obtienes un
intervalo diferente un intervalo
bastante amplio aquí para tu posible
señal así que aproximadamente
aproximadamente de 2 a 5 para la señal
en el alcohol pero podría incluso no
estar en ese rango así que solo piensa
de dos a cinco para el protón en el
alcohol como una región aproximada
ahora veamos al protón en un enlace
doble aquí un protón unido a un carbono
un protón en un enlace doble el
desplazamiento está aproximadamente
entre 4.5 y 6.5 veamos si podemos
entender por qué una manera de pensar en
ello es utilizar la electro negatividad
si pensamos en este carbono de aquí este
carbono tiene hibridación sp2 y si
comparas ese carbono con este carbono
este carbono tiene hibridación sp3
recuerda de vídeos de hibridación que un
orbital con hibridación sp2 tiene más
carácter ese que uno con un orbital con
hibridación sp3 debido a esto los
electrones están más cercanos al núcleo
podrías decir que un carbono con
hibridación sp2 es más electro negativo
que un carbono con hibridación sp3 así
que si quieres pensar en eso de esa
manera esa es una manera de pensar en
ello y entonces estos carbonos con
hibridación sp2 toman más densidad
electrónica de este protón déjame
utilizar un color diferente aquí
este carbono con hibridación sp2 toma
más densidad electrónica deslindando a
este protón y dándote un cambio químico
más elevado que un protón enlazado a un
carbono con hibridación sp3 esa es una
manera de explicar esto pero esta manera
de razonar lo no se sostiene
completamente porque si luego vemos un
protón en un enlace triple aquí si
dibujo un enlace triple y este protón
aquí podrías pensar muy bien este
carbono tiene hibridación esp y sé que
un carbono con hibridación esp un
orbital esp tiene incluso más carácter
que un orbital sp2 y entonces podrías
pensar en un carbono con hibridación esp
siendo incluso más electro negativo y
estos electrones están más pegados a
este carbono y podrías pensar bien eso
va a deslindar eso va a deslindar éste
protón y esperaríamos una señal que
tiene incluso un desplazamiento químico
mayor que este protón y eso no es lo que
observamos por lo que el protón en el
enlace triple de hecho esto se muestra
en un valor dentro de este intervalo
valor entre 2 y 2.5 aproximadamente y
entonces no es sólo la electro
negatividad en la que tienes que pensar
hay otro efecto que está causando al
desplazamiento químico en este protón
del cual hablaremos en el siguiente
vídeo y pasa lo mismo con el protón en
el anillo de benceno así que guardaremos
guardaremos esa discusión para el
siguiente vídeo hablaremos de esto y de
esto en el siguiente vídeo si
continuamos con un aldehído para un
aldehído tenemos este carbón hielo aquí
el cual toma densidad electrónica lejos
del protón en el aldehído y entonces
está deslindando a ese protón por lo que
esperaríamos que la señal de ese protón
ocurriera a un desplazamiento químico
más alto
un valor entre 9 y 10 es donde esperamos
el desplazamiento para este protón
finalmente veamos un ácido carboxílicos
la señal para este protón
aproximadamente es de 10 a 12 nuevamente
tenemos a este carbón y lo aquí tomando
densidad electrónica
tenemos otro oxígeno aquí tomando algo
de densidad electrónica así que podrías
pensar en efectos de electro negatividad
podrías pensar también en efectos de
resonancia y podrías también pensar en
que hay algo de efectos de enlaces de
hidrógeno hay todo tipo de cosas
sucediendo aquí con el ácido
carboxílicos y sobre todo si ves en la
región que va del 10 al 12 y ves una
señal piensa piensa en el protón en el
ácido carbólico